with life getting more demanding and
hectic all the time it seems there's
only one way to cope multitasking gurus
and life hackers make a living telling
us how to get better at it but can we
actually multitask the term was first
used in the 60s to describe computer
performance the human brain though is
not a computer and human attention is a
very limited resource some psychologists
model visual attention has been like a
spotlight it can only be shown in one
direction at any one time our primary
focus what we're paying most attention
to is like the brightly lit area in the
center of the beam it can also be
understood as being like a zoom lens we
can choose to narrow our focus to
concentrate in detail or widen it to be
aware of more things simultaneously but
we can't be zoomed in and out at the
same time even though we're constantly
receiving a huge amount of information
from our senses it's only possible for a
small amount to make it through to
conscious awareness watch the next
section very carefully and pay
particular attention to how many balls
bounce in the circle how many can you
count seven right but did you also
notice that little dinosaur what about
the changing shape of the circle or the
smiley face on one of the balls this
shows just how powerful focused
attention is being able to filter out
irrelevant detail is an amazingly useful
tool that it means we can miss things
that are right under our noses an effect
known as inattention blindness you can
see this very clearly in the famous
invisible gorilla experiment where NASA
concentrates exclusively on how often
basketball plays and white pass the ball
most people completely miss the gorilla
walking across the screen and beating
his chest we just don't have the
capacity to process everything at once
this is a particular problem when we try
to multitask we can switch attention
from one task to another and back again
but when attention is overloaded we miss
things and the result is nearly always
that we perform tasks less well than we
would doing
one at a time it's only truly possible
to do two things at once if they require
different sets of cognitive resources
for example it's totally possible to
read a book and listen to music at the
same time which would suggest that
driving while talking on the phone is
not a problem as long as it's a
hands-free phone it's not that simple
though research has shown that while
talking on the phone we have a tendency
to create mental images and this uses
the same visual resources needed for
driving and if visual resource has
become too stretched it's perfectly
possible for a driver to look directly
at a hazard but just like with that
little dinosaur fail to see it not
everything will make it through to
conscious awareness so multitasking
makes us up best inefficient and at
worst downright dangerous
if you're feeling like you should be
doing 17 things at once remember that's
just not the way your brain is wired
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon